[Musique]
la
perspective du monde con amatne
ma mission est de changer le point de vue des gens
sur les jeux traditionnels et de leur montrer
une nouvelle façon d'apprendre sur les femmes
boob est un jeu de mémoire en bois positif pour le corps
où vous devez trouver
une paire de seins qui correspondent à la  l'idée était
de
montrer que nos corps sont normaux et
que nous n'avons pas besoin de les
rendre parfaits un match parfait et
aussi de le montrer à
nos enfants je dois dire que milo est un
grand fan de seins
comme en général il est fan de
seins comme  comme tous les enfants, vous savez que vous
passez de l'allaitement comme
quelque chose qui les
intéresse, puis vous pouvez participer à une
conversation et expliquer d'accord
ouais mes seins sont comme celui-ci ou
cela ressemble plus aux miens et ceux-ci
ressemblent plus aux seins de tantes  ou ah ceux-ci je n'ai
jamais vu quelqu'un avec ce genre mais
oui ils sont réels et ils peuvent exister alors
quand je parle de seins avec des gens
ils deviennent un peu mal à l'
aise mais qu'est-ce que c'est comme un souvenir
avec mais comme avec  seins et  est-ce pour les
enfants
et je suis comme oui bien sûr mais ils adorent
ça
pourquoi poussons-nous le sein dans un
sujet tabou cela n'a aucun sens alors
mais c'est comme une vraie réaction des
gens qu'ils sont un peu mal à l'aise mais en
fait quand  nous jouons c'est tellement amusant
qu'elle a été fondée sur
une plate-forme de financement participatif
je pensais que nous avions l'intention de vendre environ
200 jeux à un moment donné, c'est devenu tellement viral
et
incontrôlable que c'était en fait une réponse à ma
frustration d'être parent parce que quand
j'ai eu ma fille  elle obtiendrait tous
ces commentaires sur son apparence oh
regarde comme elle est jolie regarde quelle jolie
robe et puis j'ai entendu ces autres
commentaires qui ont été donnés aux garçons et ils
portaient principalement sur leurs capacités et
ce qu'ils ont fait à quel point ils étaient forts ou à
quelle vitesse  ou à quel point capable et vraiment
encourageant aussi,
donc j'ai senti qu'il y avait quelque chose qui n'allait pas
ici et j'ai pensé qu'il fallait
aussi un moyen de montrer aux parents et de les
encourager à montrer aux filles des femmes avec une
vraie histoire derrière elles
qui d  c'est comme une chose incroyable dans le monde
et qu'ils peuvent inspirer les filles à faire
ce genre de chose pour que le look ne soit
vraiment pas votre objectif de base
[Musique]
nous sommes vraiment
confrontés à ces normes corporelles
que nous voyons partout quand j'étais
ado  j'ai essayé de m'adapter à ces normes corporelles
et j'ai essayé d'avoir l'air d'avoir vu que les
femmes me ressemblaient autour de moi dans les
magazines ou sur Internet, c'est
beaucoup de pression et ce n'est pas facile d'
accepter que vous puissiez avoir une
forme de corps différente que
je porte  Je ne pense pas que je me qualifierais
peut-être d'activiste et
d'inspiriste,
ce serait plutôt un mot pour cela en
ce moment, c'est un moment difficile et
stimulant pour nous en Pologne pour les
femmes sur les droits des femmes mais aussi sur
l'égalité pour tout le monde,
mon espoir est  changer le point de vue des gens
sur la diversité et la tolérance et j'espère
que nous pourrons tous contribuer à
des
conditions et un environnement plus tolérants pour les enfants
j'espère qu'ils pourront vivre
entourés d'
acceptation et d'encouragement